an Indonesian valerant player has been
accused of using cheating software
during a VCT qualifier that bypasses
Vanguard and enables aim assist the
alleged cheat software was named
netflix. exe which may ring a bell for
some of you who remember one of the most
prolific Esports scandals in
[Music]
history hasn't been that long since I've
been on here so y'all should know the
drill by now hit the like button the
Subscribe button and ring that
notification bell for me I heard your
head shot percentage goes up by like 50%
if you do just what I heard though
before we start I want to give a huge
thank you to Susie blr and son for their
willingness to clarify and add context
and new information the story would not
have been possible without them so thank
you we did it y'all valerant finally has
its own word.exe moment pack it up cuz
it's it's all downhill from here one of
the most famous incidents of cheating in
CS came in 2018 when Optic India player
forsaken was found to have cheating
software installed and I named the file
word.exe in an attempt to hide it from
officials at 2018 extremes land but
officials saw right through it and
disqualified his team from the event it
was an absolute watershed moment for
competitive Counter Strike and raised
some serious questions about competitive
Integrity across Esports at the same
time it became an international meme
across the entire FPS scene so if
someone hits an insane shot and you hear
them say word.exe it's a joke some
people say that valerin copies
everything from CS well they might just
have copy cheating scandals with this
one too the alleged cheating incident
happened last week at the valerin
challengers Indonesia split one Open
qualifier according to Val 2 Asia a
website focusing on the Asian valerant
scene a Caster named bradel shared an
Instagram story with a folder called
fantech audio supposedly owned by the
alleged player ma among the files was
one in particular named netflix. exe Val
to Asia revealed that son a Caster in
the scene presented a text file that
talked about how to run the program
which included deactivating Vanguard and
activating an aim assist ma is said to
be on Tokyo Revengers one of the teams
in the qualifier Susie and son told me
varying explanations as to how these
sheets were actually discovered but both
came down to that someone rang the alarm
Bell Vanguard did not flag anything
according to Valu Asia a representative
from Tokyo Revengers has released a
statement addressing the situation my
friends and I strongly affirmed that
player ma is not using any illegal
programs anymore this is supported by
the fact that he has undergone the
antiche clearance and met the
eligibility requirements for the
tournament the same article details that
Tokyo Avengers first opponent puton
jagan felt like something was off their
opponent son also showed in their video
about the situation allegedly a
screenshot of something showing how to
disable Vanguard and open netflix. exe
when I reached out to tournament
organizers for comment they said we are
not at our capacity to give any further
comments on this as this being
investigated by Riot team so until we
hear from Riot the question is how did
this happen Vanguard is supposed to be
completely watertight if it is such an
invasive antiche that works well how did
this bypass it and how apparently as the
alleged cheaters team said in their
statement did he pass all necessary
checks we'll have to wait for Riot's
official statement on the matter for any
light on it but I have to say I have
covered cheating and valerant on this
channel before and I have been told it
is not a matter of if someone will be
caught it is a matter of when right now
this situation is just sort of being
Meed on for its likeness to the iconic
word.exe like when I asked for leads and
sources on Twitter I was told to ask
forsaken for the supposed team itself
Tokyo Revengers they lost after their
first match in the qualifier so they are
out ma the alleged player has a VR page
that only shows him playing in this
qualifier as his career as far as we can
tell this alleged incident is isolated
but with how simple and accessible
netflix. eex seems to be if this is true
is this just the tip of the iceberg and
let's be clear this all of this does not
define all the incredible teams that
were just playing their hearts out
yesterday in the qualifier so good luck
have fun to all of those teams I texted
my dad would it be proper to call this
person a Kone if this allegedly happened
he was like you want lean more towards
stunad cuz cfone is like FYI stunad is
stupid cfone is a real
what texted me